shouldn't put too much trust in our intuition we can start by writing down the density Matrix representation of the
two cubits after the workspace Cubit has been introduced and notice that we're using the kuit ordering Convention as
usual where the bottom Cubit is the left one and the top Cubit is on the right we can express this density Matrix
explicitly as an actual 4x4 Matrix as is shown on the screen and then we compute the effect
that the controlled notot gate has on this density Matrix so we conjugate by the unitary Matrix associated with this
gate once again keeping in mind the kuit ordering convention so this is the correct unitary
Matrix and the result is shown here in effect the controlled noock gate
permuted the entries of our original Matrix around a little bit so now the possibly non-zero entries are in the
four corners it remains to compute the partial trace and we could do that directly from the Matrix but an
alternative is to convert to the direct notation as is shown on the screen and then it becomes pretty easy to evaluate
what happens when we Trace out the Cubit on the left within each term and the result is that just the
terms corresponding to the diagonal entries of row survive and so we've def phased the Cubit as
expected as always check this for yourself yourself at your own pace if you choose to do that it's a good
example to get some practice working with density matrices and with partial
traces that's not the only way to implement the completely def phasing Channel here's an alternative Stein spring representation for this
channel I won't go through the calculation in detail in this video but I will show it briefly in case you'd like to pause the video and have a
closer look the way it works is similar to the first one but the details are
different this time we start with a hadamar gate on the workspace Cubit which puts it into a plus State and if
we expand out the tensor product we get the Matrix that's shown on the screen to apply the control zgate we
conjugate by the associated unitary Matrix and the result of doing that is to inject some minus signs into the
Matrix in particular the last row and the last column both get multiplied by Nega 1
and this time it would be pretty messy to convert to direct notation so we'll compute the partial Trace
directly when we Trace out the first of two cubits what we end up getting is the sum of the two diagonal 2x two blocks
and so the final result is again that we've defaced the Cubit that was quick and if you're not
used to these sorts of calculations then take your time and do it slowly speed is not important
here to finish off this example let me mention that there is a pretty simple idea behind this implementation which is
pretty nicely expressed by the last step of the calculation that we just skimmed through more succinct way of saying this
is that if we average a given Cubit density Matrix with that density Matrix conjugated by the poly Z Matrix then
that's the same thing as def phasing so the completely def phasing Channel happens to be a mixed unitary
Channel where we either do nothing or in other words we perform the identity operation or we perform a zgate each
with probability 1/2 good to know so in summary we have two different
Stein spring representations of the completely def phasing Channel and that tells us something important which is that Stein spring representations are
not unique and in fact there are infinitely many of them for any given Channel Next we discuss cross
representations of channels which give us a convenient formulaic way of expressing channels through matrix
multiplication and addition cross representations are named after Carl Krauss who is a physicist who among
other things worked out a lot of the basic mathematical details of channels and the general formulation of quantum information more broadly in general a
cross representation is an expression of a channel taking the form shown here on the screen in particular we have a
collection of matrices which here are named a z through a n minus one for some positive integer n and they specify the
action of the channel on any given input row according to the formula in short we conjugate row by each of these matrices
which are often referred to as cross matrices in this context and then we sum up the result and that gives us the output all these matrices have to have
the same dimensions and specifically their columns must correspond to the classical states of the input system and
the rows must correspond to the classical states of the output system if that's the case then when we take the product AK * row * AK dagger for any
choice of K we get a square Matrix whose rows and columns correspond to the classical states of the output system
and so it makes sense that the expression produces a density Matrix of the output system now it is not the case
that for an arbitrary choice of these cross matrices that we get a valid Channel there is however a pretty simple
condition on the matrices that guarantees that we will get a valid Channel and that condition is the formula displayed right here
specifically if we sum up the product of AK dagger * AK over all the values of K
then we must get the identity Matrix and that will be the identity Matrix whose rows and columns correspond to the
classical states of the input system so that condition must be satisfied in order for the mapping defined by the
first equation to be a valid Channel and it turns out that every channel does in fact have a representation that takes
this form as long as we take n to be large enough here are a few examples of cross
representations starting with the Cubit reset Channel we can obtain a cross representation for this channel by using
two cross matrices c0 bra 0 and c0 bra one so n is equal to two in this example
we can plug these choices into the general formula and we have just two terms so it's easy to write out the sum
and if we simplify and recognize that the expression in parenthesis is the trace of row then we see that we obtain
the Cubit reset Channel we can also check that the required condition on these matrices is met and that's a simple matter of plugging the CR
matrices into the equation and evaluating and we get the identity Matrix as is required for another example let's again take a look at the
completely def phasing Channel taking the matrices cat 0 br0 and Cat one bra one works and that can be checked by
expanding out the sum and seeing pretty directly that we get what we need and again the required condition is met an
alternative is to take a z to be the identity Matrix ided < tk2 and A1 to be
Sigma Z / < tk2 and if we evaluate we see that again we get the completely def phasing Channel based on the observation